[Música]
salud en directo América de Francia 24 y
me acompaña en el estudio más Romero
salamar bienvenida buena mañana de
viernes Ya finalizamos esta semana y
vamos a dedicar nuestro espacio de salud
para hablar de la migraña una enfermedad
que afecta a millones de personas en
todo el mundo pero que no se tiene muy
en cuenta no cómo está Raúl
Efectivamente es una enfermedad que
afecta muchísima gente pero que queda
muy invisibilizada ahora lo vamos a
tratar a más profundidad vamos a hacer
primero una vez hacer rápido de qué se
trata no es una enfermedad que genera un
dolor de cabeza de nivel pues moderado
hasta grave normalmente inicia en un
lado de la cabeza afecta solo una mitad
de la cabeza y que además no se trata
solo de los episodios de dolor que
pueden durar pues unos pocos días sino
que también se encuentran síntomas antes
o después Es un periodo largo de
afectación no A veces viene acompañado
por molestias por la luz por el ruido
también provoca náuseas no ganas de
vomitar Incluso en los casos más graves
problemas de movilidad o pérdida de
fuerzas lo provoca el sistema trigémino
que es un nervio que en las zonas más
profundas del cerebro hasta las capas
periféricas y pues viene dado por una
alteración de la producción de
sustancias inflamatorias y esta
inflamación es lo que genera el dolor de
cabeza hay predisposición genética pero
también hay factores ambientales que
influyen por ejemplo una buena o una
mala dieta la alimentación dormir bien o
mal el estrés también y a veces viene
asociado también con las personas que
sufren depresión o ansiedad Vamos a
repasar brevemente las cifras antes de
seguir en todo el mundo afecta
aproximadamente mil millones de personas
una cantidad abrumadora de gente se
calcula que además provoca 41,1 millones
de años vividos con discapacidad en
todas estas personas que sufren la
migraña y además es la primera causa de
discapacidad entre las mujeres menores
de 50 años porque es tomar porque las
mujeres se ven afectadas de
proporcionadamente por la migraña Pues
por un lado hay un factor hormonal que
viene dado por ejemplo los cambios
hormonales del ciclo menstrual estos
cambios hormonales pueden desencadenar
migrañas o episodios de migraña pero
también hay factores sociales vamos a
poner un ejemplo Y es que se vio que el
riesgo de padecer migraña se multiplica
por 1,44 para Víctimas de violencia
sexuales y físicas sabemos que la gran
mayoría de estas víctimas son mujeres
también afectan las desigualdades
sociales no todo esto son cifras de
Estados Unidos el 40% de las personas
que recibieron un diagnóstico de migraña
en Estados Unidos estaban justo por
encima o en la línea de pobreza entonces
precisamente puede ser eso por ese esos
factores ambientales el estrés el estilo
de vida no poder alimentarse bien no
tener tiempo para mantener una vida
saludable o el dormir mal no Claro todas
estas cosas afectan de hecho
desproporcionadamente siempre a las
mujeres también a la población lgbti
personas racializadas o personas por
ejemplo nativoamericanas en el caso de
Estados Unidos entonces pues bueno así
la migraña sea una enfermedad universal
que afecta a tantos millones de personas
hay una carga desproporcionada en las
mujeres y en las sectores pues
socialmente desfavorecidos por alguna
desigualdad y porque incomprendida la
migraña Pues realmente a pesar de que
mil millones de personas la sufren y es
una causa de incapacidad muy importante
muchas veces se desestima se valora como
un simple dolor de cabeza no no se
considera un problema urgente es una
enfermedad que además a no ser que el
paciente lo reporte pues no se vea no
ser que sea una crisis muy grave
entonces todo esto nos explicaba a Paula
cadance ya es neuróloga especializada en
migraña que además también nos asesoró
Pues para todo el resto del programa
escuchemosla la gran mayoría de las
personas o de los pacientes no dejan de
asistir a su trabajo A pesar de estar
enfermos a pesar de estar discapacitados
por lo mismo porque se cree que el
paciente entre comillas puede de cierta
forma inventarse el dolor el paciente
que llega con migraña básicamente muchas
veces se piensa que no es tan importante
y puede manejarse rápidamente
Sin condiciones óptimas para atender un
ataque o una crisis de migraña y esto
pues ha generado Pues un estigma
importantísimo en el que las personas
consideran que estos son dolores de
cabezas normales cuando no existe un
dolor de cabeza normal
leer la cabeza digamos en unas
condiciones normales de salud Qué
consecuencias tiene el estigma sobre la
migraña más Pues lo principal es que el
diagnóstico se suele retrasar mucho no
las personas viven durante años con
migraña sin saber que tienen migraña
repasamos las cifras de un estudio que
hizo una universidad italiana vieron que
en una muestra de personas recogidas una
en 16% de las personas sí recibían un
diagnóstico de su migraña antes de un
año pero más de la mitad lo recibieron
después de 5 años de estar viviendo con
migraña por esa precisamente pues poca
valoración por parte a veces de los
mismos pacientes pero también del
sistema de salud además vemos Esta cifra
de 5 años pero hay personas que llegan a
vivir una década dos décadas con
migrañas y nunca acudir al médico
recibir un buen diagnóstico un buen
acompañamiento también porque sabemos
que hay desigualdades precisamente que a
veces no que las personas puedan llegar
a una buena a un buen sistema de salud a
una buena atención médica y claro todo
esto qué pasa pues que hace que se
cronifique esa migraña no pasa de ser
algo quizás episódico a algo crónico que
afecta además constantemente a la vida
laboral familiar social del paciente y
siempre muy invisibilizado no también
además trae otros problemas como el
consumo excesivo de analgésicos y de eso
también nos hablaba Paula cabanzo esto
es como un círculo vicioso el sobreuso
analgésicos empeora el dolor se hace que
el que la migraña sea más refractaria
los tratamientos y más difícil de tratar
y fuera de eso pues los temidos riesgos
del sobreuso o mal uso de analgésicos
que son la falla renal la falla hepática
alteraciones gastrointestinales
hemorragias y entre estas otras Pues
también intoxicaciones
claro como decía para cerrar la doctora
no hay un dolor de cabeza normal al
menor síntoma Buscar acompañamiento
médico porque pues en la medida de la
posible de lo posible esperemos que
todas estas personas que sufren migraña
puedan acceder ese acompañamiento a esos
tratamientos que existen y que realmente
pues permiten mejorar la vida la calidad
de vida de los pacientes Así es mar y
también eh Como lo estábamos hablando
cuando estábamos escuchando a la doctora
muchísimas personas también a lo mejor
nunca en su vida se enteran y tienen un
diagnóstico de migraña y viven toda su
vida con esta enfermedad es importante
hablar de estos temas Pues en Estos
espacios para que más personas pues
sepan que esto es una enfermedad no es
un dolor de cabeza simple es una
enfermedad que tiene que ser tratada e
ir al médico Pues a tiempo para hacer
diagnosticado mal como siempre Gracias
por toda la información feliz fin de
semana nos vemos el lunes con más salud
hasta el lunes